(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] So!
We were booked-
- [Mario] This is great.
- [Kelly] Thank you!
So as,
you were at the tree lighting as well,
that's the most recent place
we were at the same place.
- [Mario] That's right,
that's right.
- [Kelly] Did you have a good time?
- [Mario] I had such a good time-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] It was so much fun.
I think it was like my
eighth year doing it.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- [Mario] And by the way,
you are awesome.
- [Kelly] Oh, thank you!
- [Mario] By the way.
You looked beautiful in that white coat.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Thank you!
It wasn't mine!
- [Mario] I was like what?
- [Kelly] My stylist,
it's actually Makayla,
my stylist,
and she was, I was
supposed to wear dresses,
and last minute I was like, "Oh hell no".
- [Mario] No.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- [Mario] I was thinking
about it because it was so,
I felt like cryotherapy out there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] It was so cold.
How was it?
I was like,
"Oh, how is she singing in like-
- [Kelly] Oh, I was very terrified.
Yeah, yeah.
And then I was just like,
"Lord, if you love me at all.
Just like,
I'll take a few notes off key,
but if you could just
kind of keep me in line
most of the time."
- [Mario] Take the wheel.
- [Kelly] It was really funny.
- [Mario] Barry Manilow was cool too.
- [Kelly] I cried though!
The tree?
I've never experienced it physically
in person like being turned on
and I didn't realize it was gonna happen.
It's so beautiful.
- [Mario] It is beautiful.
The spruce?
(Kelly gasps)
They call it the spruce.
- [Kelly] It looked like we
were in freaking Whoville.
- [Mario] It did, right?
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Mario] I always say it feels like
we're inside a snow globe.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Mario] Like there,
it's like a Christmas movie.
It's awesome, and it
kinda officially kicks off
the Christmas season,
so that was awesome.
- [Kelly] I know. Savannah
and Hoda were laughing at me
'cause they were like, "Are you crying?"
And I was like "Yes".
(Mario laughs)
I was like, "It's so beautiful."
- [Mario] That's awesome.
- [Kelly] Anyway,
so do you have any
family holiday traditions
that y'all do?
- [Mario] I mean, you know,
we have the family come over
and everyone kind of
hangs out at Casa Lopez,
and my wife being Italian
and us of course being Mexican,
a lot of food,
good food,
(chuckles)
hanging out.
So we're eating a lot,
drinking a lot.
- [Kelly] Once again,
just like Annie,
invite me over,
I'll come over.
- [Mario] Hey, let's do it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] It's a big party,
so we're good.
- [Kelly] I love Italian and Mexican food.
- [Mario] Dobby Diego did it
again. When we went canoeing
I told him to wait for me at the bank.
I thought he knew I meant the river bank.
Not blank.
What did you say?
- [Dobby] I'm just gonna say Money bank.
(audience laughing)
- [Mario] The money bank.
Yes.
That of the financial kind.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Go go.
What did you say?
- [Dobby] Yes!
Um, I said side bank.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Mario] Side bank?
- [Dobby] Not the river bank,
uh, but the side bank.
- [Mario] When you be at Wells Fargo
and you go cheat with Bank of America,
that's your side bank.
- [Dobby] That's your side
bank! Okay! (audience laughing)
- [Mario] Huh.
All right, not a match.
- [Dobby] America knows.
- [Mario] Not a match-
- [Dobby] No it's not a match.
- [Mario] But I appreciate the guess.
(whooshing)
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I love it!
We're back with Mario Lopez y'all!
(audience cheering)
So...
It's like a dream job for me.
I love games so much.
- [Mario] I love to host games.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- [Mario] I love games too.
- [Kelly] Explain this one.
- [Mario] So this is a lot of fun.
I give um,
the contestants sort of
funny clever fill in the blank.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] Sort of questions.
And they have to try
to match their partner
and guess what they're gonna say.
And they get points,
and whoever has the most
points at the end wins.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Mario] And so we have like
a couple regular contestants,
I say regular 'cause we
have some comics too,
to kind of help punch it up and stuff.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] But it's funny
and it's fun.
- [Kelly] Oh I love that.
- [Mario] And there's nothing
better than giving away money.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] You give away money to people
it's the best feeling in the world.
- [Kelly] Oh my god,
it feels so good.
So, we have another thing in common.
We both love sneakers.
I love shoes.
- [Mario] Yes!
- [Kelly] You have a new shoe line?
- [Mario] I'm so excited
about this. Uh, Kel look,
I'm rockin' 'em right now.
- [Kelly] I love!
(audience cheering)
- [Mario] Lopez's shoes.
The Croc,
the Croc versions.
You know,
they're lightweight,
and comfortable
and stylish.
You can dress 'em up,
dress 'em down with a suit,
and best of all they're affordable.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] Not gonna break the
bank, which is really cool.
So we're really excited
about the shoe line. We
got all kinds of styles
that are coming out,
so good stocking stuffers,
right?
(Audience laughing)
For out there.
And also exciting,
'cause we just came out with
a new flavor of tequila.
It's a cristalino.
- [Kelly] We have so much in common.
- [Mario] I brought
some for your staff too.
I brought cases for your staff
as a housewarming gift.
(audience clapping)
Oh look we got-
Oh look at your staff,
your staff's on point right here!
- [Kelly] Stop!
(audience cheering)
- [Mario] This is the cristalino.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- [Mario] You down for a shot?
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Mario] To the good life!
Kelly!
- [Kelly] It's five o' clock
somewhere!
- [Mario] I love you so.
Ay.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] We'll do a little one.
We'll do a little one.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
Baby shot.
- [Mario] Here we go.
- [Kelly] Like your Modelito.
(chuckles)
- [Mario] Modelito, very good.
I like your Espanol.
- [Kelly] Oh, I feel sexier when I say it.
- [Mario] Okay.
(audience laughing)
Salud.
- [Kelly] Okay, salud! Okay.
- [Mario] Here we go.
(audience cheering)
Pretty smooth right?
- [Kelly] That's clean!
- [Mario] You like that?
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Mario] Good.
- [Kelly] 'Cause sometimes I go.
(smacks lips)
You know after it?
No, that's really good.
- [Mario] Yeah.
She took a pause
and I was like uh oh.
- [Kelly] I wanted to.
(Mario and audience laughing)
No I wanted to take the moment.
That's very clean.
(Kelly gasps)
- [Mario] Dang, you
took that like a champ.
- [Kelly] Oh my god,
and it's warm.
- [Mario] And it's warm, exac-
- [Kelly] I could've used
this at the tree lighting.
- [Mario] I was gonna
say at the tree lighting.
Exactly, I was just gonna say.
- [Kelly] So wait,
what are your thoughts.
I can't believe this, I'm
kind of angry about it,
but I heard you just turned 50.
Whatever genetics.
- [Mario] Oh my god.
- [Kelly] But you look incredible!
(crowd cheering)
- [Mario] Thank you.
- [Kelly] But I feel like,
I feel like life gets better
the older I get.
- [Mario] Well what's funny is,
you just said you just turned 50
and then I heard the audience go. (gasps)
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] (laughing) Dang, I'm not dead!
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] No!
- [Mario] I'm not dead.
- [Kelly] No! They went,
they went 'ugh'
'cause they're offended.
Like...
- [Mario] Well you can't
lie about your age anymore,
'cause you know people
just google you now.
Back in the day, you
used to be able to lie,
but now you can't,
'cause they'll just google you.
But um, it kinda messed
with me a little bit,
I was a little bummed to be honest.
And kind of afraid,
I don't know why,
and then I just kinda leaned into it.
'Cause I was like,
it beats the alternative, right?
- [Kelly] Not making it, yeah.
- [Mario] Yeah, exactly.
And now,
and now you know, I like it.
It's, it's uh.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mario] It is what it is.
Hittin' the fifth level,
so I'm excited.
- [Kelly] I'm with you though,
I think it's a blessing age,
because not everybody gets to grow old.
- [Mario] Right, exactly.
- [Kelly] You know what I'm saying?
So it's like.
And 50's so young now.
You know what I'm saying.
- [Mario] That's what I say.
50's the new 30.
- [Kelly] No it is!
Because scientifically
we're living longer.
Yeah!
- [Mario] Exactly.
You know what's a trip?
Turning 50,
it marked my 40th year
in the entertainment business.
'Cause I started when I was a little kid,
as a 10 year old,
which is wild.
- [Kelly] Do you think you'll ever retire?
Or you just love being busy?
- [Mario] I wanna be like
the Latino Dick Clark
and just keep going.
(audience laughing and cheering)
- [Kelly] I love that you said Dick Clark
with an accent.
(audience cheering)
- [Mario] I wanna keep going.
- [Kelly] I love it!
- [Mario] Yeah.
- [Kelly] So what's new on
Access Hollywood right now?
What's happening?
- [Mario] Oh it, well,
we're just uh, about to
kick off award season,
so we just-
- [Kelly] Oh yeah!
- [Mario] Which is nice.
- [Kelly] That's fun.
- [Mario] 'Cause the red
carpets and stuff are back.
- [Kelly] And it's fun
now because. Yeah, Covid,
it was kinda taken away for so many.
- [Mario] Yeah, but we got
the award shows comin' up,
and it's always fun.
You get to talk to most,
like you,
the most interesting, fascinating,
talented-
- [Kelly] And everyone's
generally in a good mood,
they haven 't lost yet.
- [Mario] Especially the Golden Globes,
they haven't lost yet.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- [Mario] You know,
it's TV and film,
so everybody's happy.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's how you
catch 'em in the beginning.
- [Mario] Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
- [Kelly] All right everybody,
you can see Mario on Access Hollywood,
check your local listings
for where to watch.
And his new game show
is called 'Blank Slate',
it premiers January 8th on GSN.